mes larmes je tends à rayer la petite
souris viendra y met une pièce pendant
la nuit
j'ai comme croire la petite souris
nettoie cette merde tout de suite le far
west en 1882 c'est une époque un endroit
horrible
regardez c'est la glace pourquoi ils en
prennent autant pour pas que ça fonde
mais c'est toute une organisation
la faute et il y à mille manières de
mourir dans l'ouest des bandits les
animaux sauvages les maladies tu connais
le choléra la mer noire l'amer de noir
il est sorti par la bid suis accueillons
une nouvelle venue dans notre paroisse
bienvenue dans notre charmant village
c'est quoi le problème à la fois tous
les ans il ya des morts commencent à
vendre bouge plus
il y en a qui meurt à la fin il y en a
qui meurent à la fois
quelqu'un dans cette ville va se faire
descendre comment il est mal tiré pas si
soirée crac crac six tubes à ce gala au
cours d'un duel tu seras un vrai héros
je me suis jamais servi d'une arme en
fait je vais t'apprendre à tirer
c'est mon commune va gérer tu fais c'est
la première fois que tu vas voir ça la
prestation universelle je suis vraiment
d'accord c'est ça c'est ce que je vois
juste là oui c'est ça c'est ça va de la
halle à mais c'est juste l'extérieur ça
y'a plein de repli où l'attend je ferme
ma bible alors je sais que tu es la star
qui rendent les graines
des candidats suscitent attends attends
attends regarde ça regarde nos ombres on
se connaît à peine mais bon quand on se
plaît on le sert quand je sens que ça
vient je te donne une tape sur la tête
au quai albert à l'ouest